can you let us know exactly which laws have
been done away with and which still remain
today i wonder if an adventist who asked that
question it is very simple by looking at the ten
commandments aaron violated the ten commandments
in some form or fashion the bible says
sin is a transgression of the law romans
5 verse 19 as by the obedience of one the
disobedience of one many were made sinners so by
the obedience of one shall many be made righteous
adam disobeyed adam sinned and the only way to
sin is transgress the law faith and works page
56 paragraph page 56 paragraph one and two
now we want to understand what sin is yet
it is the transgression of the lord this is
the only definition given in the scriptures
adam broke what law there was no ceremonial
law when adam sinned are you following me
there was no ceremonial law when lucifer
sinned in heaven and we know from first john 3
8 he that committed sin or practices sin is of the
devil for the devil sinneth from the beginning for
this purpose the son of god was manifested that
he might destroy the works of the devil when
certain sin there was no ceremonial system but
he sinned because the law of god always existed
the works of his hands of verity and judgment
all his commandments assure they stand fast
forever and ever and are done in truth and
uprightness psalm 111 verse seven and eight now
the commandments of god are forever the solemn law
was introduced because of sin are you following me
when sin is no more all sort of ceremonies will
be no more with respect to the ceremonial system
it pointed to christ that's why first corinthians
5 7 says christ our passover is sacrificed for us
all was fulfilled in jesus that is why when christ
died at the moment he died the veil of the temple
was torn not from bottom to top from top to bottom
god was bringing an end to the sacrificial system
what was nailed on the cross was the sacrificial
system not the law of god which is the standard
by which people are judged ecclesiastes 12 13-14
let us hear the conclusion of the whole matter
fear god and keep his commandments for this is the
whole duty of man that duty extended before adam
sinned the whole duty of man for god shall bring
every work into judgment with every secret thing
whether it be good or whether it be evil the law
of god is the standard of judgment if it had been
nailed to the cross what standard would god have
to judge the law of god the ten commandments are
eternal the ceremonial system was temporary
because of sin but the law existed before sin
so it was a ceremonial law nailed to the cross not
the ten commandments because if you say the ten
commandments were nailed to the cross you must say
thou shalt not kill has been nailed to the cross
and who believes that who believes thou shalt
not commit adultery was nailed to the cross
people make that argument to get rid of the
sabbath satan's attack is really against the
sabbath as you look at all this pandemic and the
coronavirus and all the restrictions the world
will come to a place where we realize we need to
get back to god we need a day that there will be
sunday the ultimate aim is the destruction of the
sabbath great controversy page 582 paragraph one
from the very beginning of the great controversy
in heaven it has been satan's purpose to overthrow
the law of god it was to accomplish this that he
entered upon his rebellion against the creator and
though he was cast out of heaven he has continued
the same warfare upon the earth to deceive men
and thus lead them to transgress god's law is the
object we had which he has steadfastly pursued
behind all of this is an orchestrated attempt
by satan to overthrow the sabbath commandment
which elevates god as a creator because as the
creator he has a right to rule that's why god
told jeremiah to tell the surrounding nations
jeremiah 27 verse 5 i have made the earth
the man and the beast that are upon the ground by
my great power and my outstret arm and have given
it unto whom is seen meet unto me god is saying i
have a right to decide who sits and who comes down
because i am the creator satan wants to overthrow
that commandment but in order to do that he tempts
people to try to get rid of all but eloise says
whether satan accomplishes his aim by overthrowing
one commandment or discarding all 10 the result
is the same because whosoever shall keep the whole
law and offend in one point he is guilty of all
the object of satan is the overthrow of the law
of god particularly the fourth commandment
which elevates christ as creator amen amen
you